für diese unglaubliche Pasta alimone
brauchst du nur einen Topf bzw eine
Pfanne wir fangen aber nicht mit der
Pfanne an sondern mit kochendem Wasser
da rein schäle ich die zeste von meiner
Zitrone wir aromatisieren quasi das
Wasser mit dem wir gleich unsere Pasta
kochen in die Pfanne habe ich ein
bisschen Butter gegeben Knoblauch klein
machen und in der Butter anschwitzen
Wasser hinein und wir können immer
weiter nachschütten wenn unsere Pasta
mehr Wasser braucht jetzt gebe ich auch
den Zitronensaft dazu so können die
Spaghetti während des Kochprozess den
Zitronensaft aufnehmen einmal Salzen das
ganze und der ganze Prozess hat einen
Vorteil wir müssen nicht nur weniger
spülen sondern wir haben auch die Stärke
von den Nudeln die ganze Zeit über in
unserer Pfanne das Wasser schon wieder
verkocht wir sind jetzt den Rest drauf
dann war es ungefähr ein Liter jetzt
fügen wir auch die Butter hinzu nach
Augenmaß geben wir jetzt ordentlich
Butter rein schmelzen die freuen uns auf
ein tolles Ergebnis wir gehen mit ein
bisschen Parmesan dran noch mehr Bindung
noch mehr Geschmack Petersilie wenn ihr
das hier seht ihr würdet auch denken
dass ich Sahne verwendet habe habe ich
aber nicht nur Stärke
ich glaube ich bin verliebt probieren
wir
wow